profit to plan next year's parade
reporting live in downtown las vegas
hector mejia
8 news now all right thanks hector also
for this veterans day
attractions on the las vegas strip are
honoring those who have served our
country and are currently serving too
bianca holman is live at the mirage with
more on that good morning bianca
hey good morning you know we've been
spending the morning with our dolphins
our three musketeers as i like to call
them
k2 where are they at k2 osborne
and maverick i remembered i remembered
so erica is here with us she is the
dolphin curator she's here to
share more about what is featured here
at the dolphin
exhibit and also the secret garden out
here at the dolphin habitat
we have our different training sessions
all throughout the day right now we have
jen over here and she's working with our
three male dolphins
when you come in we open at 10 we're
open from 10 to
session at four but you can come in and
see all of our different training
sessions those occur
on the half hour every hour and then we
also have all of siegfried and roy's
beautiful animals in the secret garden
all the lions tigers and leopards
wonderful and so this is just also a
great family-friendly event
i know we've got some kids again at home
they're learning from home they're off
today
but of course parents are looking for
those field trips to bring them
somewhere similar like this yes if
you're looking for
a a little field trip to get out of the
house this is a great place to come
we've got educational material that you
can come
you can pick up for all the different
age groups and make it an
educational learning field trip to come
out here to the dolphin habitat your day
out yeah for sure and of course let's
get back to veterans day uh again a
wonderful day to celebrate our men and
women who served in the military our
armed forces
or again who've retired since then so
what do you all have special for them
uh so if you're an active or retired
military
you just show your id you get in for
free and then up to five of your family
members can get five dollars off for
coming in
also one more thing if you stop by the
mlife desk
and sign up for an mvp card you'll get
added discounts at all the mgm
properties
i know they love to hear that be sure
you know there's a lot of places that
give our military discounts so again
they're going to probably definitely
come and take advantage of that and it's
not only today
this is today and all the way until
sunday so again if you're out there you
got some plans already set
you can come on thursday friday saturday
or sunday so you got the whole weekend
decided you got plenty of time to come
out and take a take a day off
yeah and again put a smile on your
spouse's face who served in the military
or father
or mother again giving that time to
honor them
and what they all that they do for our
country and we're going to send it back
to you guys in the studio
bianca is live out there with the three
musketeers those are some smart dolphins
bianca so beautiful
thank you very much